is a toxic podcast what's toxicity
okay let me tell you something yeah I
came from a marriage right and I had to
separate from my partner for a part wow
like say why you separated them from she
separated from her husband because he
might cheat not because he cheated
because he might cheat and the longer
the conversation went on the more she
changed it and now she's on this podcast
she's changing it again separate right
and I said for the sake of my child
we're trying to co-parent and heal our
relationship hold up are you on the show
yeah now now let me land let me learn I
said because of situations
[Laughter]
see now she's made herself look like an
idiot because they didn't realize who
she was until now she's mentioned it the
guys on the left are like oh yes I
remember this clip
slightly contradictory
that was me coming in yeah what I'm
saying is me saying that and I've said
I've gone through my trials and
tribulations right and I didn't realize
how hard marriage or whatever was and
plus the Western culture influenced me
in a certain and this is a culture yeah
this is this is what modern women do
like they they want to paint the story
in the way that they're like even when
they it's weird even when they take
accountability they like don't they'll
be like oh well it was the culture that
influenced me and I Did It For My Child
because it's what's best for my child
and it's just like no but the future you
were a selfish modern woman that put
yourself before your kid she's talking
about her culture this is a woman that
grew up in a was it 16 children because
there has been a dad had two wives so I
think there was like 14 or 16 children
but yet she's talking about her culture
and going on social media I'm trying to
unlearn that and I'm trying to go back
to what I want to be a feminine
[Music]
woman right so I said whatever I'm doing
I'm going she then told me that I left
my relationship I've she said that she
said that she left because her husband
might cheat we didn't say it she did in
my child's life and I'm going to further
ruin my child's life because we were
talking about the statistics of bringing
up a child in a single parent home I
even asked her is it cheaper to live
together or to live apart she said it's
cheaper if we live together I said well
if you've got a three-bedroom house and
you're going to live separately why
can't you take one room your husband
take one room and give your child the
other room and at least make it look a
bit better also she said she didn't she
did she not to them now that she
actually went out looking for looking
for men she actually said that on the on
the podcast that she actually went out
there on dating apps and she wanted to
try day in and see if she's going to
move on but yet still she was waiting
for her husband waiting like I think she
was giving herself a break of three
years and I think somebody says that
when when a woman says that she wants a
break of three year she just wants to go
go and um and see what's happening in
the streets well and the other thing is
like
she volunteers all this information we
don't have to go back to ever because
she got you got you so much the podcast
and you'll see pearls it's well why are
you why are you giving us all this
information it's like based on what you
said and then we comment on it yeah and
it's like all we do all I do is hold up
the mirror yeah and and if your husband
doesn't want to be with you it's like
why why and and that means you have to
work on something and it it to get back
to that spot and that's what and you
probably want to tell her to do not have
a break for three years how can you say
I've got to go and find myself and and
he's got to go and find himself and
that's why we said that she seemed to
got everything backwards because she got
married then she had a child now she
wants to go and find herself how can you
find yourself when you're apart from
your husband you're working on you
you're working on him and then she said
oh if we get back together in the end
it's like oh we you can't be saying you
want to get back together because you've
been out there looking and the only
reason when you're going to get back
together because
that's why you're going to decide that
you want to go back otherwise you'd be
working on your marriage you wouldn't be
working on yourself you need to work how
can you work separately and then come
together you're going to be two
different people still well and then the
other thing she would talk about and
again guys the only reason I commented
on this is because she volunteered all
this information there was like four
other girls in the room who didn't talk
and and the thing is she would talk
about how she's going to live as a
feminine woman and I kept asking her
like what did you do to be feminine and
she kept giving me these broad answers
that didn't make sense like like a real
answer would be
um that I don't know I learned I learned
to cook like a bunch of different
recipes yeah um I'm actually you know
I've invited my husband like if I wanted
to get back with my husband like I I
cook him dinner on Fridays yeah and
appall and truly apologize for working
her way towards him again right but she
would just give me these broad ass
answers and the thing is that would
contradict everything she said because
if you're doing this what feminine women
aren't freaking on dating apps and that
Carnival but when she first spoke for
about I don't know it's half an hour an
hour she didn't mention that she had a
child because I remember when she
mentioned the child I was the first one
to say well hang on a minute it's
different now because you've now got a
child you know that makes it even more
reason to try and make it work for the
marriage because you have a child but
she spent so long being selfish thinking
about herself talking talking about
herself what she wants or what she wants
to go on dates and she's going to do
this she's going to do that and then all
of a sudden up Pops his child out of
nowhere and we were all surprised that
she actually had a child because as a
mother you mentioned your child
especially if you're a child at Primary
School the child is young enough you
can't come and sleep you mentioned your
husband you mentioned that the ABS you
mentioned everything and then eventually
it slips out that I have a child and
everybody's view changed after she and
she couldn't handle it and then and then
she talked about yeah I'm now a
traditional woman and I would just be
like okay I'm sorry you cannot be a baby
mama because I you cannot be I'm sorry
you can't be a baby mama that's at
carnival and I'm just I'm just reading
back what you
volunteered who left her husband because
he might she or maybe she said it was no
she kind of she doesn't she said my I
always remember that she said my no I
said yeah I started by saying that he
said like that because I I think at
first she kind of made it seem like she
left and then later when she started to
look bad she like switched it yeah and
that was the whole point was like and I
don't God only knows I don't really care
because she even said that because her
dad had another word had two wives that
if her husband turned around and said
you know I want two wives she could have
worked with that or even thought about
it but what he actually says is that you
know she said oh would you do this and
he said well you know it turns out that
he might so she left her husband because
he might but yet she contradicted
herself and said that if he said he
wanted another wife like her dad she
would have thought about it because that
is not off the radar for her have being
a second wife like you and Jess going
off statistics though I don't care
they don't care about statistics because
sir I understand statistics
before everyone speaks guys we're all
content creators I'd live in and jumping
over each other and he's talking to you
two in the middle and he's talking to
you two in the middle and this is the
thing on that podcast I remember ending
it thinking I barely freaking talked
yeah because this girl and and this is
one of my weaknesses as a host is
reigning in these crazy guests that's
why I need to join you sometimes I know
I know we should do like Wednesdays or
something yeah let us know let us know
in the comments what day yeah
let me let me finish yeah with the
statistics I don't care what statistics
she wants to put me in I'm not a single
mom who's got no education I've got a
full Masters right I've got a full no
one cares you that doesn't mean you can
raise a better child and what I what I
went off of was the fact that you you
said you were at carnival you you said
that you're a single like you always all
the information you volunteered there
was like three other girls on the
podcast there was another single mother
she didn't volunteer any of this
information about her baby daddy and you
know it's not feminine going around
telling your business on a podcast yeah
that so if you're living as a feminine
woman and you're chatting all this [__]
about your baby daddy like does that
that's not what feminine women do but
that Epica hardly said anything and also
there was a girl on there that said that
she don't care what she says that if she
goes to Carnival as a single woman she's
looking man remember there was a girl
that said that because the girl said to
her no I don't believe you if I'm going
kind of as a single woman I know what
I'm going for I'm going to to look for a
man and oh no no bloody degree in
politics as well international relations
right I did my thing I've got my whole
career and I went into a marriage I had
my child things didn't work out I'm not
a statistic my child is yes you are
you're a statistic come on you're a
statistic they're telling you you are a
statistic you've made yours she could
have been a statistic of you know
happily married women with you know nice
family with a child that is a statistic
that is a good one she don't want to be
the single parent statistic but that's
what she's made herself and if you don't
want to be it don't be it go back figure
it out like get on your knees and beg
beg say you'll do whatever it takes to
bring the family back together she
didn't say we wouldn't have known no I
know and like if someone told me okay
because I'm trying to I put myself in
her shoes you're a statistic you're
between like you're one of the women
between the ages of 25 and 45 that's
single I would say yeah and I'm trying
to work on it but she didn't say it like
yeah I'm trying to work on it she's like
in denial oh oh
starting wife school go subscribe yeah
it's kids you can meet right all single
parents say that that's that's what
they're about to see yeah does not ever
go without my child will never also go
with that so you can't say that I've
just but she goes without her dad half
the week or her mother you can't say she
never goes without and I think that came
up when you said that you that your dad
was early then you'd rather your dad was
there she sent her dad was only over
there but her dad was hardly ever there
because he had two women to service
right and all these children but and the
difference is your dad was at work so
his bed was in the house he didn't sleep
anywhere else he came in the house and
that's what I was saying to her that
even if they moved in with the husband I
mean she's living somewhere else and
he's got a three-bedroom house how does
that make sense well and and you know
with my dad like there is still there's
something about knowing your dad's
coming home yeah even even if it's super
late or even if he's out of town for a
week like there's something about like
you're waiting for your dad to come home
or you're like a little mini Christmas
yeah yeah yeah and it's like
you're you are a statistic and you can
try to deny it all you want but you look
delusional and that's not my fault all I
do is hold up a mirror to what you said
get mad people might separate people
might have children in different
circumstances because they're now single
doesn't mean they're ruining their
child's life because it might be you're
not single that's the whole point you're
still married benefit that you're not
single you're married alone mother two
parents have to separate that's not what
people are saying we're saying that
holistically and I love Eddie he's
always the man of reason at least
speaking that when a child is taken out
of a two-parent home you don't put them
in every statistical disadvantage of
that kid which is what Pearl said
um that's not to say that you're not a
good mother or you can't raise your
child properly that's just saying that
most women in your situation end up in
situations where the kid goals and
that's fine
you can say most women you see the guy
who left he's like which is why you fit
into this
she don't want to fit and do you and do
you let him talk no did you cut him off
again
but then is she gonna land then we're
generalizing you though in it you're
asking us you're saying no you don't
want to be in a country but then I'm
putting you in a category
my girl let him talk out of there no I'm
not saying that my child's Dynamics
especially me and her father my child
doesn't know that we've separated she
doesn't see that we're not together
right and I say this because when he
does come he'll come we'll do things as
a she never mentioned any of them she
never mentioned anything about the dad
doing anything together and picking him
up and him having her one day and she
never know the other day she never said
anything kids aren't stupid
and this is the thing this is the thing
okay the truth comes out eventually and
I swear to God I believe this with my
heart and my soul one day your kids will
grow up and they will talk and how will
they talk about you your kids will grow
up and they will talk and especially in
this day and age they're they're
probably gonna have their own podcast
about you if you [__] them up they
will watch this what are we talking
about the kid knows that their parent
that his parents are not like everybody
is his friend's parents and maybe I mean
who knows maybe the kid's too young I
don't know how old the kid was
my granddaughter came home and spoke to
her parents and she was absolutely
disgusted they weren't married she said
to her dad why didn't you marry my mum
my friend's mum and dad are married what
do you mean you're not married you take
me to school daddy you bring me home
you're supposed to start she was really
annoyed and she's trying to say that
kids don't notice at five and my
granddaughter was absolutely fuming why
won't you marry my mum what's wrong with
my mum why wouldn't you marry my mum and
her mom said I want you to head I think
you should marry my mum I can't believe
that you're not married but your mummy
and your daddy you're supposed to be
married and she reckons that he's not
going to find out he'll go to work I'll
say he's gone to work or I'm working and
he has her right does he live there no
he doesn't live there but we live 10
minutes away from each other she's now
it's 10 minutes away she never mentioned
a distance she never mentioned she just
said they lived separately and 10
minutes out 10 minutes walk 10 minutes
drive 10 minutes by the plane she's
still trying to land yeah but she won't
probably won't notice now but she's gone
and when she notices hopefully we might
be and this is what I said on the
podcast we might be in a situation where
it might work out right no she never she
says she's giving it three years which
means that her daughter will be eight
which means that her daughter would have
already known that her mum effed up her
life already so you can't say that oh
we're gonna work things out and then
we're going to move in together and the
girl ain't gonna realize that eight
years old she will know if you if you
really like I'm just like I'm trying to
put myself in her shoes right so if I
was with a guy and maybe there was
something that I did like maybe maybe I
was too jealous or I was too something
like to the point
um that he left and it was something
that I genuinely did like I swear to God
I'd be breaking my back like like it and
she's overweight men value you being in
shape yeah so so like I swear to God if
my ex-husband and I and I and I
genuinely wanted him back it like I
genuinely felt like that was the best
thing for my kid and like I don't know
what she's doing I don't know what she's
not doing maybe maybe she's doing some
of these things but if she was sure but
it's not showing because she's not doing
it yeah okay I can say it she's not he's
not doing she's not doing it it's I'd be
I'd be in the gym okay first of all I'd
be trying to look so good this is you
know what this is game this is game if
you want to get your husband back this
is what I would recommend I'm not saying
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible